양자 중첩을 측정하는 건 동전 던지기만큼 무작위적이에요 — 그런데 이 비유가 어디까지 통할까요?
오늘 'Kiss in the Classroom'에서 함께 알아볼게요
'Kiss in the Classroom'에 오신 걸 환영해요 양자 컴퓨팅 관련 수업에서 만날 수 있는 핵심 개념을 쉽게 풀어드리는 영상 시리즈예요
각 영상에는 설명란에 링크된 인터랙티브 모듈이 함께 제공되니까 꼭 확인해 보세요 오늘은 양자 이론의 핵심 원리 중 하나인
중첩에 대해 이야기해요 우리 일상에서 물체는 항상 확실한 특성을 가지고 있어요 — 위치, 크기,
모양, 색깔 — 모든 것이 결정되어 있고 확실해요 우리, 즉 관찰자가 아직 측정하지 않았더라도요 그런데 양자
세계에서는 반드시 그렇지 않아요 양자 물체는 소위 중첩 상태에 있을 수 있는데,
고전적으로 허용된 여러 상태들의 중첩이에요 측정하면 그 상태들 중 하나로 무작위로 붕괴하게 되죠
여러 고전적으로 허용된 상태들의 중첩이고, 측정하면 그 상태들 중 하나로 무작위로 붕괴해요
중첩 상태를 측정하는 건 동전 던지기와 같아요 — 어떻게 떨어질지 미리 알 방법이 없죠
이 근본적인 불확정성은 심지어 Einstein도 불편하게 여겼던 양자역학의 측면이에요
그는 이 무작위성에 대해 "신은 주사위 놀이를 하지 않는다"고 유명하게 말했죠 하지만 우리가 보게 될 것처럼, 신은 사실 주사위 놀이를 해요 — 아니면 우리 경우엔
동전을 던지죠 게다가 이 동전들은 조작된 동전이에요 양자 중첩을 측정하는 게 어떤 면에서는 동전 던지기와 비슷할 수 있지만,
중첩 자체는 고전적인 확률 상태보다 훨씬 더 풍부하고 복잡해요
이를 보기 위해, 고전적인 동전이 어떻게 작동하는지 생각해보고 IBM 양자 컴퓨터에서 qubit으로 탐구할 우리의
양자 동전과 대조해볼게요 먼저 고전적인 동전이에요 꽤 간단해요
동전을 던지면 앞면이나 뒷면이 각각 50% 확률로 나와요 원칙적으로는 동전의 정확한 초기 조건과 정확히
얼마나 많은 힘과 회전력이 던질 때 적용됐는지 안다면 어느 면이 나올지 계산할 수 있어요
하지만 실제로는 어느 면이 나올지 사전에 알 방법이 없어요 그래서 우리가 동전 던지기를 고전적인 확률 상태의 대표적인 예로 쓰는 거예요
결과가 본질적으로 무작위인 거죠 제가 이 동전을 천 번 던져서 앞면과
뒷면의 수를 기록하면, 이런 모양의 히스토그램을 얻게 될 거예요 Y축에 횟수가 있고
앞면이나 뒷면이 될 수 있으며
히스토그램은 각각 약 500번씩 나온다는 걸
통계적 변동을 감안해서 보여줄 거예요 우리는 양자 컴퓨터의 qubit을 이용해서 비슷한 상태를 만들 수 있어요 동전 던지기처럼
qubit도 0과 1, 두 가지 상태로 측정될 수 있어요 qubit에 Hadamard gate라고 불리는 걸 적용하면
0과 1의 균등한 중첩 상태가 돼요 여기 그
circuit의 시각화가 있는데, 이걸 circuit 다이어그램이라고 해요 맨 위 선이
qubit이고, qubit에 적용되는 연산들이 선 위의 상자로 표시돼요 Hadamard gate는 이 H로
표시된 상자로 나타나고, 측정은 작은 측정 기호가 표시된 회색 상자로 나타나요 그게 측정값을
두 줄로 된 이 선, 즉 고전적인 비트로 보내요 qubit이 0과 1의 균등한 중첩 상태에 있으니까 측정하면 0이 나올 확률 50%, 1이 나올 확률 50%가
돼요 qubit이 0과 1의 균등한 중첩 상태에 있으니까 측정하면 0이 나올 확률 50%, 1이 나올 확률 50%가 돼요
이 양자 중첩 상태를 s = 1/√2|0⟩ + 1/√2|1⟩로
표현해요 s = 1/√2|0⟩ +
1/√2|1⟩ 여기서 각 계수, 즉 진폭이라고도 불리는 것들의 제곱이 각 상태를 측정할 확률이에요
그러니까 Hadamard gate를 적용하는 건 동전 던지기와 유사한 거예요 동전을 천 번 던져서
앞면과 뒷면 통계를 살펴본 것처럼, KCET에서 우리 양자 동전으로 비슷한 걸 할 수 있어요
통계를 샘플링하기 위해 circuit을 여러 번 반복하는 Qiskit의 기본 요소인 sampler를 사용할게요
천 번 샘플링하면 위 circuit으로
통계적 변동을 감안해서 고전적인 동전 히스토그램과 거의 동일한 결과를 얻어요 그럼 이게 다인가요? 양자
중첩이 본질적으로 동전 던지기와 비슷한 고전적인 확률 상태와 같은 건가요? 꼭 그렇지는 않아요 만약 그게 사실이었다면
꽤 짧은 영상이 됐겠죠 첫 번째 핵심 차이점을 보기 위해, 고전적인 동전으로 조금 다른 걸 해볼게요 그냥 탁자에 떨어지게 놔두는 대신
앞면이나 뒷면으로 착지하게 하는 것 대신, 동전을 던지고 공중에서
양 손바닥 사이에 잡을게요 이제 동전은 앞면이나 뒷면이 아니라, 앞면이 왼쪽이나
오른쪽을 향하고 있어요 그러면 논리적으로 이것도 왼쪽이나 오른쪽이 50/50 확률이어야 해요
우리 양자 동전에서 앞면이 왼쪽이나 오른쪽인지 측정하려면, 고전적인 동전에서 한 것처럼 할 수 있어요
다른 축을 따라 측정하는 거예요 양자 컴퓨터에서 표준 측정은 수직 축을 따라 이루어지는데
고전적인 동전의 일반적인 앞면/뒷면 측정과 같아요 하지만 양자 동전에게 앞면이 왼쪽인지 오른쪽인지도 물어볼 수 있어요
x축을 따라 이 두 상태를 플러스 또는 마이너스라고 불러요
이를 위해 Qiskit의 기본 요소인 estimator를 사용해요 조금 복잡하게 만들자면, sampler처럼 히스토그램을 반환하는 대신
estimator는 qubit의 어떤 관측량의 소위 기댓값을 줄 거예요
이 기댓값을 이해하기 위해, 동전이 앞면이 위로 나올 때마다 1달러를 받고 뒷면이 나올 때 1달러를 잃는다고 해봐요
기댓값은 각 동전 던지기에서 평균적으로 얼마나 벌 수 있을지 예상되는 금액이에요 1달러를 얻거나 잃을 확률이 동일하므로
기댓값은 0이 돼요 qubit에도 같은 추론을 적용할 수 있어요 x축에 대한 기댓값을 구할 때, 플러스 상태에 x를 적용하면
값 +1을 얻고 마이너스 상태에 적용하면 -1을 얻어요 그러니까 50/50 분포라면
기댓값이 0이 되겠지만, 실제로는 그렇지 않아요 — 기댓값이 +1이에요
즉 동전은 x축을 따라 항상 플러스로 측정된다는 거예요 이건 동전을 던지고
잡아서 항상 오른쪽을 향하는 걸 보장하는 것과 같아요 이건 왜냐하면 중첩은 단순한 확률 분포가 아니기 때문이에요 양자
상태를 어떻게 표현하는지 기억하시나요?
상태 s는 C₀ × |0⟩ 상태 더하기 C₁ ×
|1⟩ 상태와 같아요 각 계수들은 복소수예요 즉 실수부와
허수부를 모두 가지고 있어요 그래서 확률에 대해 말해주지만, 위상이라고 불리는 또 다른 양도 숨기고 있어요